faut que je réponde texto tu as dit je
lui écris quoi soit cool quoi on voit
lui un héros j au beaucoup d'accords
soit cool
voici le monde secret caché à
l'intérieur de votre téléphone
là où les màj comme moi travaillent et
vivent ici chacun de nous ne fait qu'une
seule chose mais à chaque fois on a
intérêt à assurer messages entrants on
demande bof acquis moi qui fabrique ces
32 c'est quoi ces thèmes au gie mon pote
gilles et d'alléger problème est comment
tu fais ça je le fais c'est tout ce que
je sais tu peux nous aider
suivez-moi il faut sortir du téléphone
pour trouver le code source route à
puget net
on doit trouver le mot de passe bon
c'est quoi le nom de la copine d'alex
déjà elle s'appelle qui n'a car sarah
shourd est bien dit l'hôpital mais ça
sonne pas terrible on dirait plutôt le
nom d'un chihuahua
je trouve plutôt bien comme tu es
[Musique]
hu
personne petit le téléphone c'est priver
les gifles un sentiment différent
je suis peut-être pas fait paraître une
seule émotion
moi je te plies candy cross domicilié à
leur demanderait plus jamais de bonbons
ben oui j'ai fait une overdose
tope là ne fait pas ça ne fait pas ça ce
truc est déjà allé dans ton ventre
pistons ont fait quoi après un groupe
oppose ce qu'on doit se laver les mains
aucun trophée
[Musique]